[Musique]
non
pierre louvât un vice-président a
actuellement de l'école de foot de saint
gilles et j'ai joué à un niveau en
métropole niveau national puis arrivée à
la réunion
en 72 j'ai pratiqué en tant que joueur à
la patriote puis aux poussins et après
west et aux houches je suis devenu aussi
entraîneur au fc o et après avoir gagné
la première année la coupe régionale de
france et la coupe de la réunion la
deuxième année la troisième année même
si on avait structuré au niveau des
jeunes comme je n'avais rien gagné
je me suis fait comme on dit viré
du fc haut et je suis donc revenu sur la
saline les bains depuis 87
j'ai fondé l'école de foot de saint
gilles
notre but c'était de former des jeunes
pour qu'ils intègrent ces différents
clubs seniors est aussi de former des
gamins qui part nommé relations que je
peux avoir en métropole
de les amener à des centres de formation
en métropole
tout ce que je peux faire pour que les
jeunes puissent s'épanouir et aussi bien
scolaire que footballistiques
même si au niveau de la section sportive
on a toujours mis le scolaire avant le
sportive il faut qu'ils arrivent aussi à
avoir un niveau scolaire plus que
potable pour réussir dans la vie de
l'année dernière j'ai fait un infarctus
qui était dû au stress l'association
donc là j'ai pris un peu de recul quant
aux entraînements ce qui me manque
beaucoup parce que les enfants c'est
avec eux que je suis le mieux je peux
pas arrêter ses dents mais c'est dans
mes gènes
j'entraînerai peut-être pu mais arrêtez
avec l'association
c'est comme de la cocaïne
ceux qui sont accros moi je suis accro
et j'y arrive pas il y a aussi une chose
qui me tient à coeur
je suis club pilote au niveau de l'appel
la fondation du football d'avoir
une aide avec l'université où il forme
des étudiants pour les métiers de
l'éducation pour que l'on puisse avec
tous nos enfants avoir un suivi scolaire
depuis six ans jusqu'à 17 ans si vous
voulez la départementalisation c'est sûr
c'est le développement justement du
sport et surtout des infrastructures le
seul regret c'est que on fait des
terrains oui c'est très bien mais à côté
il n'y a rien on n'a aucune structure
d'accueil
il y a le terrain mais il ya en dehors
du terrain
[Musique]